la chronique culture le rendez-vous du
mercredi avec Joanna soudri pour faire
le point vous allez nous parler aussi de
de vos coups de cœur on imagine durant
cette chronique ah oui il faut bien
alors on va commencer avec le festival
d'Île-de-France qui démarrera ce samedi
le 8 septembre jusqu'à mi-octobre le 14
précisément alors ce festival regroupe
29 concerts en 26 lieux dans toute l'île
de France avec trois concerts chez nous
dans les Yvelines le but du festival est
d'aller patrimoine et musique je vous
propose tout de suite d'écouter Olivier
delsal qui est le directeur du
festival tous des lieux à caractère
patrimonial église château patrimoine
industriel patrimoine contemporain et
puis c'est un voyage dans le temps
puisqu'on propose des répertoires
musicaux extrêmement variés du Moyen-Âge
jusqu'à la création contemporaine des
musiques du monde jusqu'aux musiques
actuelles le concert est à la fois
l'occasion bien sûr de découvrir des
artistes mais aussi de découvrir un lieu
et on a en amont de chaque concert des
visites commentées des
conférences voilà vous avez vu cette
interview qui a été réalisée au vaau de
cernet oui vousz recnu alors c'est l'un
des trois lieux justement yvelinois qui
accueillera un concert lecture intitulé
l'appel du Levant ça sera dimanche 23
septembre à 16h30 c'est une création il
faut savoir que la plupart des
spectacles proposés au festival sont des
spectacles spécialement créés par les
artistes pour
l'occasion le concert au v CERN c'est
l'occasion pour nous d'aborder cette
grande figure de la littérature
libanaise qui a été RAL jubrane qui est
un poète né à la fin du 19e siècle au
Liban mais qui part très vite finalement
dans son enfance installé aux États-Unis
qui va revenir très brièvement au
Liban dire c'est un concert qui est
tourné autour de la thématique de l'exil
un exil géographique et puis dans le C
gibrane aussi un exil un peu intérieur
on vient d'écouter Olivier delsal qui
est donc le direct acteur du festival
d'île-de-fance alors le spectacle dont
il parlait et bien sera porté par la
voix de Michel londal accompagné par le
pianiste Franco libanais Abdelrahman
elbacha qui jouera Chopin Ravel ainsi
que ses propres compositions alors en
fait ce concert lecture s'inscrit dans
la thématique du festival puisque chaque
année un nouvel axe est défini et 2012
et bien se tourne vers les diasporas et
les musiques en
partance on a voulu montrer que l'autre
était source d'enrichissement et on a
voulu aussi interroger sur des notions
comme la mémoire la transmission le
rapport au pays d'origine la double
appartenance culturel le bilinguisme on
ouvre sur une nuit d'accordéon avec
Richard galiiano samedi prochain au
Trianon on va avoir cinq traditions de
l'accordéon qui vont être réunis sur un
même plateau de Madagascar de la Réunion
de la Bulgarie du
Brésil alors Johan vous nous parlez de
ce festival d'î-defrance ça a l'air
assez élitiste est-ce que c'est
accessible au grand public aussi c'est
accessible par exemple on a des têtes
d'affuches comme Sandra N cqué qui est
la révélation de l'année aux Victoires
de jazz et donc elle se produira la
Sigale le 13 octobre c'est d'ailleurs
devant cette salle que nous l'avons
rencontré on va l'écouter tout de
suite j'ai été conçu à Paris je suis née
à Yaoundé à 6 mois j'étais à nouveau à
Paris et à 1 an et demi à nouveau à
Yaoundé ça a été comme ça pendant
presque 15 années de début de ma vie
entre deux cultures donc la culture
française et la culture camerounaise euh
entre plusieurs langues entre plusieurs
codes sociaux différents et je pense
qu'au début ça m'a un petit peu
déstabilisé comme ça peut déstabiliser
un enfant de voilà de de de bouger
d'endroit sans savoir combien de temps
on part sans savoir où on va atterrir
puisque à chaque fois que je revenais à
Paris c'était dans un nouvel appartement
un nouveau contexte nouvelle école mais
finalement ça je pense que ça m'a donné
beaucoup de beaucoup de force
c'est-à-dire que ça m'a permis de de
d'affirmer le fait que en fait le Che
chez soi il est il est en nous et que et
que dans dans ma besacee j'ai j'ai plein
de souvenirs c'est à la fois des
souvenirs musicaux des souvenirs de
théâtre des souvenirs de littérature
très riches et très très variés on avait
envie de chansons euh qui à la fois
parle de ce de ce moment où on doit
faire un choix euh parce qu' on est tous
amenés à faire des choix dans la vie de
tous les jours tout le temps et qu'on
s'est aperçu que en fait souvent on est
on est enfermé dans des cadres des
cadres sociaux des cadres religieux des
cadres des cadres familiaux et que c'est
pas toujours évident d'affirmer sa
personnalité sa singularité son unicité
quel que soit l'endroit du monde où on
est et j'avais envie comme ça de
chansons qui qui parle de ces
questionnements là comment on fait
et qui parle de l'impermanence des
choses il y a des chansons qui sont plus
de l'ordre de de l'instinct collectif
comment comment on fait pour vivre
ensemble et comment on construit
ensemble emble une une société où chacun
va trouver sa place et d'autres qui sont
plus personnelles qui sont plus
introspectives qui parlent du moment où
on a fait le choix ou qui parle du de la
résultante de ces choix
euh le fil rouge c'est nothing for
granted ça veut dire que rien n'est
acquis c'est un genre de comme comme un
cri de guerre c'est pas du tout c'est
pas du tout pessimiste ni alarmiste mais
bien bien au contraire essayer de de de
s'affirmer elle vient de parler donc de
son nouvel album Nothing for granty WIF
je suis sû que vous avez envie d'écouter
un exima bien parce qu'on l' entendu
parler elle a une très jolie voix
j'aimerais bien voir ce que ça donne et
ben vous allez voir c'est génial son
clip s'appelle like Buffalo on va
regarder tout de suite un
extrait j'ai envie de le voir cet
extrait alors j'espère qu'on va le voir
cet extrait donc de ce clip pouvez nous
redire avec l'accent oh nothing for
granted mais il faut savoir qu'elle
parle en fait Sandra Kaké comme elle a
donc cette ce parcours elle a vécu entre
entre de deux pays donc la France et le
Cameroun elle chante souvent en anglais
et en français ça aussi puisque ce sont
les deux langues utilisées utilisées
là-bas alors on exprè voir l'extrait
dans un instant mais on va parler de la
suite du programme peut-être dans les
evelines non le clip est prêt alors on
passe au clip enfin ou
pas for
freed
to
for and all could there nothing to crazy
if
you
the always play the
sameong your mus to
be
voilà pour cet extrait artiste à
découvrir lors du festival d'île-de
France alors la programmation dans les
ivelines donc dans les ivelines on a
deux concerts lecture l'Affiche rouge le
dimanche 16 septembre au Fort du trou
d'enfer à marli Leroi et puis l'appel du
Levant le dimanche suivant le 23
septembre à l'ABE des veau de cernet et
on a une trisème date qui a encore un
coup de cœur c'est le danseur renommé
Andres marine qui est un danseur de
flamenco il invite sur scène le chanteur
aranel ils vont interpréter des chants
qu'on appelle Dida iwelta qui sont des
chants en fait parti d'Espagne vers le
Nouveau Monde et qui sont revenus
ensuite en péninsule ibérique avec bah
tout ce qu'ils ont pu
justement bah prendre là-bas au nouveau
monde voilà on voit quelques images ici
du danseur de flamenco vous jonglez
entre l'anglais l'espagnol ce sera quand
au milieu de tout ça alors ça ça sera
samedi 29 septembre à 21h à vézyie à
Londes et un dernier mot sur du cinéma
en plein air on quitte ce festival on
referme cette page consacrée au festival
d'île-de-fance donc la musique c'est
finie on passe au cinéma donc jusqu'au
15 septembre et bien les ivelines font
leur cinéma avec un peu partout dans le
département des films qui sont projetés
à la belle étoile à partir de
20h45 quelques exemples un jour de fête
à tousul noble ce samedi donc ce weekend
Les petits mouchoirs au château de la
Madeleine vendredi prochain le 14 ou
encore les vacances de Monsieur Hulo à
Versailles le samedi 15 septembre séance
gratuite programme complet retrouvver
sur Internet merci Joanin à la semaine
prochaine pour la prochaine chronique
culture vos prochains coup de cœur
culture dans le département on passe au
sorti ciné on reste dans le cinéma vos
sorties ciné vous en avez l'habitude
depuis l'an dernier chaque mercredi avec
les nouveaux films à l'affiche nous
allons à votre rencontre à la sortie des
salles restez avec nous Johanna je vous
ai vu bouger sur le fauteuil tout va
bien j'ai un peu glissé voà vous êtes
pressé d'aller au cinéma alors on va
voir ce que vous conseille les 5
contintinois en tout cas alors je suis
allée voir monsieur Lazar et j'ai pensé
que c'était une pépite un très très joli
film très bien fait très émouvant euh
fag est absolument somptueux donc je
recommande vraiment ce film mais à tout
âge en plus monsieur Lazard et c'était
très bien non j'ai j'ai beaucoup aimé
c'était très intéressant puis bon il y a
une histoire
de de vie quoi enfin je suis allé voir
Monsieur Lazar euh
donc formidable comédien fitag et c'est
un c'est un film de rentrée mais plutôt
pour les adulte le gateur c'est un beau
film c'est ACC conseillé le getateur et
c'était très bien ça nous a plu voilà
oui un bon film très bon film bons
acteurs bon film alors je suis allé voir
chercher hortans et j'ai bien aimé je
trouve que Jean-Pierre Bakri est très
bon dans ce film et l'histoire est
intéressante et c'est bien joué
killer
Jo et bien c'est assez effrayant et
c'est un
portrait un peu inquiétant de la société
américaine